[موسيقى]
في الكره كطفل بس نتكلم احنا كمحترف كشعب
محترف في غني اغاني عاطفيه خاصه فيه طبعا
يعني اعتقد انها على منتصف الستينات لكن
يعني صوته حتى ما ركز الا فيما بعد وكلهم
عموما بشكل مبكر يحتاجون وقت حتى تركز
اصواتهم تثبت يعني مسائل يعني تخص طبيعه
الصوت البيولوجيه طبعا فكل واحد اسهم ما
في شك صار عند كل واحد مجموعه شعراء
ملحنين بنوا اشكالهم كل واحد بنا اشكال
بالاضافه لانه في ميزه هنا عند الاغنيه
السعوديه ومهمه طبعا في المرحله الاغنيه
الخليجيه
الاغنيه
هذا لانه مرتبط بتعبير سياسي له علاقه
بتاسيس مجلس التعاون طبعا برغم انه اللي
اسهمه فيما يسمى باللغه الخليجيه يمكن
كوادر يعني محدوده او متمركزه في السعوديه
والكويت لم تكن الكوادر الاخرى تسهم الا
يعني اما تذهب الى الكويت او تذهب عن طريق
الكويت الى مصر مثل البحرين او او اللي
عرفت في بلدها زي قطر يعني او كذا لكن
عمان والامارات تاخر اسهامها في الاغنيه
الخليجيه باختلاف التراث بينها وبين الدول
الاخرى الاربعه طبعا لكن الاغنيه السعوديه
قلت نصف الخمسينات